ce président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la fois au ministre
de l'économie et à la ministre du
travail
le 10 octobre dernier le groupe michelin
fleuron industriel français leader
mondial du pneumatique annoncé la
fermeture définitive du site de la roche
sur yon
après joué les tours en 2013 et 737 130
emplois supprimés cette décision met fin
la production destinés aux poids lourds
en france
619 hommes et femmes qualifiées
hautement qualifiés sont concernés vont
perdre leur emploi
la moyenne d'âge des salariés de 39 ans
et beaucoup ont été recrutés ces cinq
dernières années dans le cadre du plan
skipper qui prévoyaient 100 millions
d'euros d'investissements et 200
recrutements 70 millions ont été
investis les femmes et les hommes ont
consenti beaucoup d'efforts pour
améliorer la productivité du site
cela n'a apparemment pas suffi et le
couperet est tombé brutalement
michelin propose 120 millions d'euros
pour accompagner la reconversion de
lusine suggère la mobilité interne pour
des personnes qui ont construit leur vie
familiale et professionnelle en vendée
pour certains depuis plus de trente ans
c'est une vue de l'esprit
la présidente de la région pays de la
loire cristal morancé notre éminent
collègue bruno retailleau ont obtenu le
remboursement des aides régionales
accorda michelin est ce que l'état fera
la même démarche pour une perdue cice
l'état sera-t-il présent aux côtés des
salariés et des élus locaux dont le
maire de la roche sur yon du guaje le
président du département yves auvinet
pour obtenir toutes les garanties et
amortir les conséquences de ce drame
économique et humain à long terme
cette malheureuse actualité illustre les
travers de notre économie aussi plus
généralement comment l'été tente l'état
entente il oeuvrait pour préserver et
développer l'industrie dans notre pays